everyone and welcome to the Simons
Institute breakthroughs breakthroughs
lecture today on thresholds
um so just a brief introduction so my
name is venkat guruswami I'm a senior
scientist here at the Simons Institute
and the Simons Institute is the leading
uh worldwide venue for collaborative
research in theoretical computer science
it was established in 2012 with the
generous Grant from the Simons
foundation and ever since then it has
been hosting programs in a variety of
areas in theoretical computer science
and its interface with Sciences
engineering Humanities economics and so
on and you know and the in addition to
the Thematic programs two of which run
every semester The Institute also does a
lot of Outreach activities in bringing
exciting developments of theoretical
computer science to a worldwide audience
and so it's in that capacity today's
breakthrough so today we have one of the
one such series is the breakthroughs
lecture series which brings exciting
scientific can computational
breakthroughs to a wide audience and so
before I introduce today's speaker I
will uh just a quick question a quick
update on how to ask questions so this
is a hybrid event I mean we have a lot
of people here in the room asking
questions here just raise your hand uh
easy I'll also be monitoring the the
zoom chat so if there are any questions
there you can raise your hand and just
unmute yourself and ask or type it in
chat and I'll relay the question to the
speaker okay um so with that let me
introduce
um today speakers or distinguished
speaker today is Jin Young Park from
Stanford University where she's a Sego
assistant professor working in
combinatorics and previously uh Park was
a member of The Institute for advanced
study in Princeton from 2020 to 2021 and
she received a PhD from Rutgers
University in 2020 under the supervision
of Jeff Khan her doctoral work earned
the 2022 dissertation prize from the
association for women in mathematics
and before she started Graduate Studies
she worked as a mathematics teacher in
secondary schools in Seoul from 2005 to
2011. so uh and today she will lecture
today's talk is about thresholds I think
it will be hard to get a shorter title
than that it conveys a lot and with that
please join me in welcoming engineer
for this invitation is my great pleasure
to give a talk in this amazing place so
I'm going to talk about thresholds today
and so here is my plan for today so in
this talk I'll introduce the Khan kalai
conjecture which is a central conjecture
in probabilistic combinatorics and then
discuss our results related to it
but we first start with a brief
introduction to random graphs just to
begin with a concrete picture in mind
and also historically random graph
theory was the starting point of our
story but later we'll see that the
setting of our work is much more General
so let's let me first talk about random
grabs just briefly
and here we use GMP for the random graph
so GMP is the Airbus uranium random
graph or whose definition is this so the
vertex set of GMP is the bracket n which
means the set of integers from 1 up to n
and here we think n is finite but it's
very large so it's like one thousands or
thousands millions billions it's a large
fixed number for finite number
and so because we have n vertices so
there are n choose to potential edges
and we choose each Edge or independently
we'd probably with probability p
so
for example or so this is a little
example of GMP when n is 3 and P is one
half so in this case we have three
vertices so here we have eight graphs in
our sample space and because p is one
half so every graph in our sample space
has the same probability which is one
over eight but as we change it as we
change the value of P the probability
distribution also changes so for example
if p is very small like 0.0001 in that
case the sparse graphs are much more
likely on the other hand when p is close
to one then the denser graphs are much
more likely
so GMP is not a fixed graph but this is
a probability distribution so it makes
sense to ask questions such as what's
the probability that GMP is planar or
what's the probability that GMP is
connected Etc
and in those questions we are not
exactly interested in finding the
precise probability for those events but
whether we are interested in um what's
the typical behavior of GMP for given
probability PA or as we change the
values of P
and so for that in this talk we are
going to use the term with high
probability and when we say GMP does a
with high probability that means the
probability that GMP does a tends to one
as n tends to the infinity so in our
work the usually the interesting range
of P sorry usually p is a function of N
and usually P tends to zero as n tends
to the infinity so so usually like P is
like 1 over n or log n Over N so
something
a function in N that tends to zero s n
tends to the infinity that's our
interesting range
and one striking thing about GMP is
appearance and disappearance of certain
properties are abrupt and this gives us
the notion of thresholds so one way to
view the behavior of GMP is this
Evolution model which means we think as
we think of GMP as we add edges one by
one at random so for example when p is
zero when we are here then there are no
edges so this is our starting point but
at the end when p is one we see all of
the potential edges which is n choose
two
and as we slowly increase P from 0 to 1
we view this as we throw random edges
one by one each time
so that's the evolution model of GMP and
in this model so one typical example is
this so when we think about the typical
maximum size of connected components of
GMP so here I say typical because as I
said GMP is a probability distribution
so we we are interested in the typical
behavior of GMP
and when we look at the maximum size of
connected component of GMP then if n
times p is slightly smaller than one
slightly smaller than one in this case
the maximum size of connected components
is very small so it's at most in the
order of log n so this is very small
compared to the number of vertices in
gmk
on the other hand when n times p is
slightly larger than one then suddenly
we see a giant component whose order is
as large as n
so in this sense we can say that P
equals 1 over n is more or less the
threshold for having a giant component
so this is where the phase transition
happens when we look at the maximum size
of the connected component
and this is just one example and we see
something like we see this like
interesting base transition for many
other interesting properties so it
became a natural interest it so
naturally it became a central interest
in probabilistic combinatorics to find
thresholds for various properties
okay so here I put some of the past
results on binding thresholds and I'm
not going to read all of the results in
this list but I just wanted to show my
audience that so this is indeed a long
studied area and many researchers have
worked on the problems in this area
also when you look at the list you'll
see that study on this area has been
done mostly for specific properties so
for example what's the threshold for GMP
to have a small subgraph for example
having a triangle or having a click
having a fixed size click or was the
threshold for GMP to have a perfect
matching so those are some specific
properties but later we'll see that the
conjectures are just a unified Bound for
the location of thresholds which
includes
um all of most of these results listed
on this list
so that's where where we are heading to
but for that I think I need to intro
this emotional threshold first
so okay but do we have any questions so
far
you mentioned connectivity I mean please
do different things how you know did I
say that
the last one oh so this spelling tree
this means is the given the given type
of Spanish tree yeah okay
do we have any other questions
okay
so we're going to talk about okay let me
introduce ratios
so basically this slice contains all of
the basic definitions that we are going
to talk about today
so so as I said the conquer like the
setting of The Counter light conjecture
is much more General this is something
beyond the beyond the random graph
Theory so here we use X4 or finite set
and this this x can be anything so we
are not necessarily stick to the random
graph setting so X is a finite set and 2
to the x is as usual the power set of X
so this is the collection of all of the
subsets of x
and we use mu P for the P biased product
probability measure on 2 to the X which
means for any subset a of x
new P of a is defined to be P to D the
size of a times 1 minus P to the size of
the complement of a and then we use XP
for the random variable whose
distribution is Mu P so this is simply
speaking this is just a p random subset
of X which means we choose each element
of X with probability P independently so
this is the meaning of a p random subset
of x
and then maybe it looks familiar to us
so for example if we take X to be n
choose 2 which means the the set of all
of the edges in KN where k n is the
complete graph on N vertices in yes so
if we take our ground set this way then
XP is just GMP which is really random
graph because we choose each pair or
each edge with probability P
independently or we can also view this
as the edge percolation on the complete
graph kn
so under this definition the random
graph model is just one example of this
model and another model that we can
think about is if we uh if you choose if
we set X to be the collection of all of
the K Clauses from n variables then we
can view XP as a random CNF formula so
here x really can be any finite set and
we can think about this random model On
Any Given finite set
so let me introduce the notion of an
increasing property and basically this
is a generalization of the many
properties many properties that we
consider and simply speaking on
increasing property means we can't
destroy this property by adding an
element that's a simple description
description of this property but
formally speaking we say f is an
increasing property if whenever B
contains an element in F then B is also
contained in F so for example in the
random graph in the random graphic
example the property that the graph
document graph is connected this is an
increasing property because we can't
destroy this property by adding an edge
and also another example is to contain a
triangle because again we can't destroy
this property by adding up by adding an
edge and another example is so if we
think about random CNF formula then
another example for an increasing
property is to be not satisfiable
so in my mind on increasing property
looks like the picture on the right hand
side so this big circle or small circle
is 2 to the X with the natural process
structure so we have the empty set at
the bottom and we have the entire set on
the top and for example in the first
layer we have all of The Singletons and
in the second layer we have all of the
double tones Etc with the natural
process structure so for example
whenever we have an element a in this
increase in property then everything
that contains this element a is also
contained in the increasing property
okay so those are the basic definitions
and do you have any questions so far yes
you listed the previously
well I think so yeah I can't go back but
yeah
oh yes that's true so everything is
from this definition page
okay now let me introduce thresholds a
well-known fact is that for any increase
in property f as long as this is not not
the empty set or the entire set
or mu P of f which is by definition the
probability that our random variable XP
is satisfies the given increase in
property F this is continuous and
strictly increasing in p
so this continuity is very easy to see
this is just from the definition so when
you look at the definition of mu P of a
this is just a polynomial so mu P of f
is just a sum of so many polynomials so
this is again polynomial so obviously
this is continuous and this strictly
increase in property I'm strictly
increasing this is
um this is a baby example of a coupling
argument but let me not go into the
details but by this fact we know that if
we draw the graph of mu P of f then this
graph looks like this so as we increase
K from 0 to 1 mu P of f also increases
from zero to one
and one simple example is the
connectivity so for example if you think
about the connectivity then if p is zero
then of course the probability that GMP
is connected is zero because it's just a
bunch of isolated vertices so the
probability I mean so in this case mu P
of f is precisely zero on the other hand
when p is one then the probability that
GMP is connected is exactly one because
all of the edges are present so we are
here
and we know that as we increase P from
zero to one the probability that GNP is
connected or XP satisfies so given
increasing property also increases from
zero to one so we have this this
increase in graph and then
because this graph is continuous and
strictly increasing so of course so
there must there exists something called
PC of f for which u p of f is exactly
one-half and this PC of f is called the
threshold for f
so roughly speaking the threshold is
where the phase transition happens
because this graph says that if we are
below the threshold then it's less
likely or it's unlikely
that our random variable XP satisfies to
give an increase in property F on the
other hand if we are above the threshold
then it's much more likely
that XP satisfies F the given increase
in property F so this is where the base
transition happens and this is
definition of the threshold but if
you're familiar with the random graph
Theory then you have seen the definition
of on erode Serenity threshold which is
defined this way
so it says so the threshold in this
sense the threshold is if p is much
smaller than P0 then u p of of root P of
f n is it tends to zero as n tends to
the infinity so here here we consider a
sequence of or increasing property or
sequence of ground set or sequence of
the increasing properties and if p is
much larger than P0 then this
probability tends to 1 as n tends to the
infinity
so this is a classical definition of an
area or threshold function but by a work
of Boulevard and tobesen we know that
our definition of PC is always on
average Humanity threshold and moreover
if we apply our definition then we don't
have to consider a sequence of events or
sequence of increasing properties so in
that in some sense our notion of the
threshold is much more convenient to
work with
emotionally
okay
so there are roughly two interesting
directions of the study of thresholds
the first look at the first direction is
about location of thresholds which is
the main theme of today's talk and as I
said historically most of the
interesting work was on thresholds for
specific properties and then the kankali
conjectures are just a general bound so
what happens to as a preview what
happens is this so given an increase in
property F we are curious about the
location of each threshold we want to
find it but usually this is very hard to
find
but in in many cases there is something
called Q of f let me let me we're going
to Define it later but let me for now
let me just call this Q of f there is
something called Q of f which always
gives a lower bound on the threshold and
then the calculate conjecture says that
this PC of f is also bounded above by
this easy lower bound Q of f times some
tiny error term
so if this conjecture is true then the
location of the threshold is trapped in
in this tiny window so there's a rough
statement of the kankali conductor and
so yeah so the most recent result is the
proof of eye contactor
and another direction of uh the story of
thresholds is called the sharpness of
thresholds and there are okay many
interesting work in this direction and
all of the all of those work is based on
free analysis so after they got this
those results as far as I know people
try to use free analysis to prove the
kankali conductor but again as far as I
know uh it didn't it didn't go well and
so it turned out our proof of the
conductor has nothing to do with free
analysis it's very much like
combinatorial
okay so yeah so let me okay let me move
on to the next part the calculator
and in this part I'm gonna give my
audience the what what motivates the
conquer light conjecture and so the
authors of the council this is a very
strong conjecture and even the authors
of this conjecture said it would be it
would probably be more sensible to
conjecture that it is not true
and so in this part I'm gonna introduce
four examples and through those examples
what I want to do is to give a building
to see why this conjecture is believed
to be nonsense or why people believe
that it should be untrue anyway so the
question behind so the fundamental
question behind this conjecture is this
what drives the threshold and we're
going to examine four examples to build
up some observations for of to answer
this question
and in the first example our X is n
choose two so our random variable XP is
GMP and uh the given increase in
property is to contain a copy of H where
H is this tiny graph and the question is
what's the threshold for GMT to contain
a capital h
and so here in this question we are
interested in the number of copies of
age in GMP so this is a numerical random
variable and whenever we have a numeric
random variable the first thing that we
want to check is its expectation so we
start from its expectation
so if we compute the expected number of
copies of H's in GMP then this is object
so this means Optical constant Vector we
are going to ignore constant vectors in
the following in the rest of the talk
so this expectation is equal to n to the
power times P to D5 where this into the
4 is the number of potential copies of
H's because H has four vertices so we
have roughly n choose four many h's and
then this p2d5 is the probability for
each H because H has five edges so the
probability for each H to exist is p to
be is precisely P to divide
so this expectation is n to the 4 times
p25 and we know that this tends to zero
if p is much smaller than this value
and this tends to be Infinity if p is
much larger than n to the negative four
fifths so in this sense we can say that
the threshold for the expectation is
equal to n to the negative perhaps or
per constant Vector because this entry
negative four Pips is where the base
transition happens in terms of the
expectation
but so if you're familiar with a random
graph Theory we know that oh sorry so
first of all we know that this entry
negative four fifths is a trivial lower
bound on the threshold because if the
expectation goes to zero then X is zero
with high probability so so by the
definition of the threshold if the
threshold must be at least as large as n
to the negative four flips so this gives
a trivia lower bound but okay but we
know that
and it's well known fact that the
threshold for this increasing property
is actually equal to entry negative
purpose this is easy using the second
moment method
so from this example we see that there
is a close relationship between the
expectation calculation and the actual
threshold so at this point maybe we can
dream that the expectation predicts a
correct uh threshold and if this is true
then it would be uninteresting yes
[Music]
using it a few times right well I mean
just for this one well I guess yeah both
of those I guess so the second one being
same order which is constant factors and
the first one is has the same meaning so
we just ignore all the constant factors
we just focus on the order yeah
okay and then also this means much
smaller so but the ratio test is now
okay yes all right basic question I
guess this argument applies to any
subtracts sorry this threshold applies
to any calculations such as Finance of
graph right
okay so we have the second slide
okay
so we have the second question my second
example which will answer your question
okay
laughs
so in the first example you know it's
like a freshman stream so we have this
we observed this one example and then we
dreamed that or the expectation
calculation always predicts the right
threshold but that's not true
so in the second example we consider
another small example when another small
graph which is K so now K is this
and then the question is the same what's
the threshold per GMP to contain a copy
of K
and again we start from the expectation
calculation and so the expected
expectation is n25 times p26 so if p is
much smaller than this then expectation
tends to zero and then we do the same
calculation to see that the threshold
for the expectation is n to the negative
5 over 6 of the constant vector and
again this gives a trivial lower bound
because as I said if expectation goes to
zero then there is no copy of KV type
probability so we can ask the question
is the threshold equal to distributed
lower bound but in this case the answer
is no the truth is the threshold is
equal to n to the negative four over
five
then why do we have this difference but
there is a reason for this difference
discrepancy so here it actually n to the
negative four over five this is the
threshold PC or if you still remember
the previous example this is PC of FH
right so this means the threshold is not
determined by the expectation of K but
the expectation of H
and in general this is true this was
proved by elevation rainy and balabash
so lawfully speaking for any fixed graph
K the threshold for having the threshold
for containing or copy of K is equal up
to a constant factor to the threshold
expectation of the densest subgraph of K
so in this case when you look at k
but this is the part of this graph is H
in other words as soon as we have we
contain a copy of age then this tail is
it doesn't matter it tail just follows
in this density of the edges
so yes so this result results by
elevation raining and bullabash tells us
that whenever we are considering a
plexograph then basically we know
everything about the threshold because
the expectation calculation just gives
us the right threshold so we are done
with a fixed graph and then what's the
natural Next Step because we are done
with a fixed graph so the next step is
to consider a growing graph
so in the next example we consider a
perfect matching where perfect matching
means this so we have this joint Union
of edges that covers all of the vertices
this is perfect matching and our
question is the same was the threshold
for GMP to contain a perfect matching
of course we have the assumption that to
Device end because otherwise this
problem doesn't make sense
okay so okay we start from the
expectation calculation and this gives
us 1 over n so the threshold for the
expectation is 1 over n
and then so trivially the threshold is
at least one over n and the question is
is the actual threshold equal to 1 over
n but in this case the answer is no the
threshold is log n over n
and in the previous example we saw that
as long as we consider the best the
dances to park okay sorry the density is
the stock graph of the given graph then
its expectation gives us the right
threshold well when we look at the when
you look at the perfect matching there
is really no densest part it's just
whenever a software you choose we see
the same density so there's really no
density part and so that means there is
really this non-trivial gap between the
actual threshold and the expectation
threshold
okay so we have this non-trivial Gap
then what do we do next we want to
understand why this why we have this Gap
and that's the next slide
so this is where we are we know that as
long as we consider a perfect matching
the threshold for the expectation is one
over n while the actual threshold is log
n over n
but actually this log n Over N is
another trivial lower bound on the
threshold this is because of the fact
that if p is much smaller than log n
Over N then GMP has an isolated vertex
with high probability and because now we
are considering a spanning graph so as
soon as there is sorry as long as there
is an isolated vertex then of course
there's no perfect matching so this
gives us another obstacle from having a
copy of um a spelling graph
and let me elaborate this problem just a
little bit more
so this fact is due to the coupon
collector problem uh so the situation is
this I guess everybody is familiar with
this Elementary problem but let me
explain this so this problem says this
each box of cereal contains a random
coupon and there are n different types
of coupons and the question is how many
boxes of cereal do we typically need to
buy to collect all of the end coupons
and here I put typically because again
so if you are terribly unlucky then it
will take forever to collect all of the
coupons but we are looking at the
typical behavior and here another
important assumption is the coupons are
uniformly distributed and which is not
exactly close to to the reality so in
reality usually there is some coupons
that are impossible to collect anyway so
in this ideal situation
the answer to this question is n Times
log n so we need to buy n Times log n
Mini or serial to collect all of the
different coupons and then how does this
coupon collector problem related to our
isolated vertices so in our setting we
have n vertices and those are our two
points
and as I said random graph model can be
viewed as we throw random edges one by
one so in that model throwing edges can
be seen as we buy cereals
two at a time
so and then this coupon collector
problems is that if the number of edges
is much smaller than n Times log n
then typically we have an uncollected
coupon which is an isolated vertex and
then this the number of edges
corresponds to the value of P much
smaller than log n over n
because there are roughly N squared many
potential edges out there
so this tells us that if p is much
smaller than log n Over N then typically
there is no perfect match or no spelling
graph
okay so we just saw this so there are I
mean okay so this is the third example
and let me consider one last example and
in this example we change our uh Branch
set now X is n choose R which means we
have n vertices and then we collect all
of the r topples out of those n vertices
and then in this model XP is a random
random or a uniform hypergraph HR and P
which means we choose each our Topo with
probability P independently
and then in this yeah in this model we
ask or people ask for saying question so
when R is larger than 3 what's the
threshold for HR and P to contain a
perfect matching and of course here we
assume that our Device end and here a
perfect matching means a collection of
these joint articles that cover all of
the vertices
okay so this is called xiaomiers so this
this problem was suggested by Alicia
mirror so this is called shamir's
problem and this was this question was
very hard but okay so for example when R
is 2 then somehow this problem was very
easy and this was already proved by
irrigation Renee in 1966 but somehow
when R is larger than 3 then this
problem gets much much harder and
basically this is because when R is
larger than 3 then we don't have an
analog of host theoremortus theorem
where we have very weak analog of those
theorems so that makes this problem much
harder than R equals 2 case
anyway so this problem was notoriously
open for about 30 years and but we can
think about some like easy lower bounds
as we observed before so for those
calculations let me fix R equals three
and if we start from the expectation
calculation then we see that the we can
compute that the threshold for the
expectation is or equal to n to the
negative 2 up to a constant Factor so
this gives a uh the first lower bound
on the other hand if we consider the
coupon collector behavior of collecting
where this I mean the coupon Collective
behavior of the isolated vertices then
from there we have a second lower bound
which is log n Over N squared so here
again we see this login gap between the
first lower bound and the second lower
bound
and it was proved by Johansson Khan and
boy in 2008 that the actual threshold is
log n Over N squared and this was a very
hard result and they received a focusing
price out of this work and so and it
took about 30 years to prove this
contexture and here again we see this
login Gap again
so it's time to summarize all of our
observations
so the fundamental question behind our
behind the cancelli conjecture was what
drives the threshold and from the
previous examples we saw some trivial
lower bounds on the location of
thresholds so from the first from the
first two examples we saw that the
threshold for the expectation gives a
lower bound on the location of the
threshold and from the last two examples
we saw that the coupon collector-ish
Behavior pushes up the first lower Bound
by log n
so there are some easy ways to get lower
bounds and historically in many many
interesting cases the main task is to
find a maximum upper bound
and so in this situation the kankali
conjecture roughly says that for any
increasing property the threshold is at
most log X times the expectation
threshold and so as I said this is a
very strong conjecture for example this
immediately implies historically very
hard questions for example the example
that we just saw so thresholds were
perfect hypergraph matchings uh which is
proved by Johannes and Khan and vu
so this is how the conjecture works so
we can easily compute that for any given
R the expectation threshold for having a
perfect matching is n to the negative R
minus one so if we apply the calculate
conjecture then we have this upper bound
both this upper bound Matrix but the
second lower bound which is starting
from the coupon collector coupon
collector Behavior
so this hard question I'm so so this the
calculate conjecture I mean if okay so
if the sorry if the color conjecture is
true which we know now is true
then this just what so then this
immediately implies this hard question
is just one line computation
and so another hard question is the
threshold for boundary degree spanning
trees and this is called the three
conjecture and this is recently approved
by Montgomery a few years ago and again
in this question uh we have we have an
easy lower bound and the kankali
conjecture gives an upper bound that
matches the trivial lower bound the
second lower bound
so those are some hard uh problems that
are implied by the calculate conjecture
and if you compare the years of those
problems then this can color conjecture
comes before those work so this means at
the time the concave conjecture came out
those problems were still widely open
and actually as far as I know those
questions were the motivation for the
conqueri conductor so people were people
people wanted to solve those problems
but those problems are so hard and if
you have some hard problems and if you
don't know what to do with them then
what do you do
one thing that we can try to do is to
make those problems even harder
so they just contacted maybe we can just
say that for any increase in property
the the threshold is at most the the
easy lower bound Times log n which
immediately implies those hard questions
okay I see many hands
okay so yeah I was gonna say it looks
like you've converted the problem into
one of getting a better lullaby I
converted the problem getting robot
getting better
conjecture we're still left with in
general is left with the issue of doing
a better lower back
oh okay so little will say that there
there are some easy ways to be able more
about a low band which is Logan better
than the expectations oh aha oh okay
um
no I'll I don't think there are very low
because there's more more about matches
so these people collectors were about
matches the overlord now that's in some
examples but in general you still have
this lovely example
yeah sometimes we have long ago and
sometimes we don't have others are
coming that's a little icy okay okay
yeah
no so we are still in the stage to find
the patterns so there are questions with
like not just login Gap but some
straight some things or Gap with which
is something much smaller than log n and
we are still trying to find the pattern
what what is size the gap between the
lower bound and
sure
so for the uh for containing that graph
with the tail it seemed like the true
threshold was like more than a lot of
times away from the expectation
threshold rate yeah I mean you you had
to correct it by just considering the
like densest subgraph but how would you
correct that uh expectation threshold in
general if it's not you know like the
it's called okay yeah so because it's
okay it's because so in in those
examples what I introduced was not the
true definition for the expectation so
I'm sure the patient is coming because
that's the course
so this is
yes but in that context 1060 millions of
graph that gives the highest expectation
threshold in other words it's the number
of edges divided by number of properties
to
okay so now okay it actually is here
so what's the expectation to ensure as I
said in the previous examples it was
pretty obvious to see what what whose
expectation we want to compute but as I
said in our say our city is much more
abstract and if the given increasing
property is just any abstract thing that
it is unclear whose expectation we want
to compute so we need a careful
definition for the threshold for the
expectation and so this is the
definition page okay so we start from an
observation and in this observation we
give a lower bound on the threshold
and the observation is this so we say
that we know that Q is a lower bound on
the threshold if there exists some
hypergraph Gene some some collection of
sorry some collection of set G inside 2
to the x that satisfies the following
two properties the first property is
called G covers F this means whenever we
have an element for every element in F
we have an element in G such that a
contains B so whenever we have an
element a in F we have another element
in G so this this is a this is
definition of a cover
and
it's bigger than these okay
so I think when we talk about for
example when we talk about like vertex
cover or Edge cover so what was the
vertex cover that means we want to cover
all of these edges all of those edges
with vertices so in that sense vertex is
smaller than edges
so
for everything enough something happens
this is
okay so another another visualization of
this picture is this so This Is by 2 to
the X my favorite two to the X picture
and or the increasing property looks
like this and then a cover looks like
this
so this means if we collect everything
above each element in this cover then
this contains F so I say so this I use
this symbol so I introduce this symbol
only for the proof part but I'm not sure
if I if you have time to go over the
proof part
foreign
okay so then okay then let me just let's
just stick to this picture okay so this
is the picture of copper so this says if
we are consider the opposite generated
by G which means we collect every
element of each element in G
so the opposite generated by G contains
the the increasing property F so this
means gives this is what it means by G
covers F and the second property is this
if we consider this quantity then this
is not large this is small and actually
what's in the left hand side is
precisely the expected number of s's in
g s is in xq
so here what is Q to the S this is the
probability that s is contained in X
cubed
and then we just add them out so this is
precisely the expected number of essays
that are contained in the random subset
X cubed and then we we say so we give
the Restriction that this expectation is
not large and as long as we have the
expectations small then this Q gives a
lower bound on the threshold
so the justification of this observation
is straightforward but let me not go
into the details you can do that I mean
this is very straightforward sorry
oh so x sub Q is just another way to say
x of P so X of P was the P random
software which means we choose each
element with the key and xq is you
choose its element with probability
independently
okay so again the certification for this
observation is very straightforward and
long let me not going to that one but
instead let me connect this observation
to one of our past exam
so in the second example
we consider the increasing property to
contain a couple of K so in my 2 to the
X picture the increasing property looks
like this right so this circle is the
collection of all of the graphs and then
F consists of all of each graph that
contains at least one copy of K
okay
and in this picture there is an obvious
choice for a cover we can just take G1
to be all of the labeled copies of case
which means G is just to this
then you see that obviously G covers F
because the opposite generated by G
contains the increase in property f and
in this case we have to check the
calculation in number two excuse me so
the expectation I mean the calculation
in number two is just the expectation
calculation for each for the capital
case so in this case this expectation
calculation we did this before this
calculation gives that Q is at most n to
the negative five over six our first
lower bound so it tells us this n to the
negative pi over 6 is the first lower
bound on the threshold
but in that example we saw that we can
do better we have a better cover
so this time we can choose Street 2 to
be all of the labeled copies of H's
where H is the densest part of K
and if you choose H this I mean if you
choose G2 this way then the expectation
calculation gives us that Q is at most n
to the negative four grips and then so
we have this better lower bound on the
threshold
so the lesson from this observation is
whenever we have a copper we when when
this cover gives us a lower bound on the
threshold and different cover gives can
give us different lower bounds so the
natural definition for the expectation
threshold is we just choose the maximum
on all of the lower bounds
so yeah and again this is a trivial
lower bound on the threshold because we
chose the maximum on all of the lower
bounds so this is again a lower bound
and then the formal statement of the
pancoli conjecture is this so it says
that there exists a universal constant K
so K comes first K does not depend on
anything and K is a reasonable constant
so in from our proof case about 1000 but
we haven't tried to optimize K so I
believe it can be much smaller
but I don't think it can be one or two
but it can be like 100 I think we can
achieve that anyway so there exists a
universal consonant Decay such that for
every finite set X and the increasing
property F the threshold is at most K
times the expectation threshold Times
log of the size of the universe so this
is the formal statement of the concili
conjecture
and in the next part I'm going to
introduce our results and if time allows
them maybe some of the proof
for me to relax the notion of the color
in something like
the approximate cover or something yes
yes it's coming for me yeah okay it's
coming
so yes so that's the first yes what will
we get with triangles
probably I'm sorry if we had triangles
uh it would be a weaker
so if our increasing property is to
contain the capital triangle instead of
is it a question construct a cover by
using a triangles in this example oh
yeah sure in this example if you use a
triangle then it will give us more about
the one over n
which is smaller yes
G2 is optimal even though
um
you mean is this the optimal lower bound
yeah of course well expectation of
course yes because it matches your
product yeah but is there a direct way
of putting that okay so this is the
definition for the expectation threshold
and expectation threshold is not always
the best more about because of the login
yeah so sometimes the people collect
against the better look very lower much
foreign
okay
but yeah so far it looks very hard to
compute the optimal cover basically but
there are some other things coming
so the first
um result in this direction is a
conjecture of telegram which is called
the fractional version of the calculate
conjecture
so in this version We Define the
fraction expectation threshold for f but
I'm not gonna I don't want to give the
uh the precise definition for this but
roughly speaking this just means we
replace the cover G by a fractional
cover which means so a coverage can be
viewed can be can be regarded as a zero
one function defined on two to the X but
we just replace this zero one function
by a real valued function and then we we
apply or we apply something similar to
the definition of a cover so we consider
a fractional cover and then we and then
that gives that again that gives a lower
amount on the threshold and then we
choose the maximum on all of the lower
values
and from this definition of course the
fractional expectation threshold is on
Opera Bond and the expectation threshold
because the copper is just a special
case of a fractional cover and because
we always choose the maximum
so a fractional expectation threshold is
always an upper bound on the threshold
but this is still a lower bound on the
threshold
and then while we proved a couple of
years ago is this result so this is this
was a conductor of telegram and this was
proved by Frankston canariana and myself
so basically we proved the con color
conjecture but with p e replaced by P E
star compression expectation threshold
and then what was better was we replaced
log of the size of universe by L of f
where L of f is the size of a size of a
largest minimum element of f which means
so for example
okay so this if let's say this is f then
L of f means we could we consider all of
them minimal elements of F and then we
choose the maximum size this is L of f
so in particular if we consider the
containment of a fixed graph in that
case L of f is always a constant so that
means in this inequality there is no gap
between the the threshold and the
fraction sorry between the threshold and
the fraction expectation threshold their
equal up to a constant vector
so this is weaker than the tank light
conductor here I said weaker because of
this fat because diffraction expectation
threshold is an upper bound on the
expectation threshold so this does not
address this Improvement anyway but what
was important what was interesting about
this result was in all of the known
applications the expectation threshold
is equal to the fraction expectation
threshold up to a constant vector so
this means all of the results followed
from the calculate conjecture is also
implied by the fractional version of the
calculate conjecture so our result in
the past already gives all of the
applications of the tank light
conjecture
and what's better I think in application
wise this was useful because it so
because we could when we consider the
fraction expectation threshold then
using the lp Duality there is a way to
give an upper bound on the expected or
the fractional expectation threshold and
the way we apply this contact or this
result is to compute that upper bound
given by the output Duality and that
gives us an upper bound on the fraction
expectation threshold and so that gives
us an upper bound on the actual
threshold and that upper bound matches
the trivial lower bound so that's how we
can nail down the actual threshold
and the proof of this conjecture was
inspired by always lobe U and Zhang on
their breakthrough in Urdu shrado
sunflower conjecture and yeah but yeah
and the proof of this conjecture was
pretty short so our in our pay our paper
itself is not very short because we have
to contain all of the many of the
interesting applications of this result
but the actual proof part was about four
pages so it was not very long
and so this was one of the results and
after we got this result of course
people the natural next question was
what's the gap between the expectation
threshold and the fraction expectation
threshold so as I said you know in all
of the non-applications the expectation
threshold and the fraction expectations
ratio they have the same they are equal
to a constant Factor
and indeed it was conjectured by
telegrams that for every increasing
property the two parameters are equal up
to a constant vector
and of course this conjecture implies
the equivalence of the concili
conjecture and the fractional version of
the canker light conjecture and before
we proved the tanco like conjunction
recently this proving this conjecture
was regarded as the most likely way to
prove the control eye contactor
and we made some partial progress so for
this contexture this conjecture is very
hard even simple instances of this
conjecture are not easy to establish and
talent himself suggested two test cases
which is proved by the Marco and Khan
and Frankston Khan and myself separately
but even for these test cases we needed
some like some non-trivial proof
argument yes
the P Star Wars than p
is this
worse in the sense like why not just
State the whole conjecture in P star if
you dealt with it
um because I don't know it's hot
because considering a cover is more
natural because we are doing discrete
math and then
so it's a part of your computer we
consider the fractional version compared
to the discrete version or something oh
no it's not like that so uh oh and also
if it's okay so the origin of this
conjecture is from the graph containment
and then in that version we just think
about the containment of stress so we
just consume actually in some version of
this conjecture people just constantly
Define the expectation pressure to be a
fixed subgraph like computational takes
the software we don't consider all of
the customer so in that sense
considering this expectation pressure is
much more natural activity
probably
for the typographic for example to get
anything from the factual version or
yeah so it's like a virtual version
gives an ah you mean a lower bound or an
upper bound
so fractional pressure always gives a
law about
right but you already proved in the
previous result that the fraction
version of the outcome right
so if you like just that theorem to the
typograph match if you get the result
so okay so like I don't know if this is
a good way to say but the integer
version so we solved improved the
integer version of the control light
projector but so far we didn't find any
audition of that okay so yeah I think I
should have I shouldn't say this
but that's just application wise but
theoretically I think you know through
giving or giving about using the copper
is much more of an element than keeping
a fractional cover and I hope that we
can find this on theoretical application
for that anyway okay
so
the conjecture scale of the telegrams
conjecture yeah so I can say that I mean
so we are still working on this
conjecture and I can say that at least
we know some something more than what's
written here but still the general
conjecture is quite an ocean
okay so this is
um because this is the this is approach
before we prove that can collect vector
and then house or what would be marked
is now that we prove the concali
conductor we know that the fraction
expectation threshold is at most K times
the expectation threshold Times log of L
of f which means if L of f is a constant
then we know that there is no gap
between the fraction expectation
threshold and the actual and the
expectation pressure so
hard to say anyway so this is
the current status and then the most
recently we proved the conqueria
conjecture this is proved by myself and
with with them so yeah we proved this
conjecture with and we still keep this
Loft app so this means if L of f is
small then there's no gap between the
expectation threshold and the actual
threshold which matches the result of
polavage and airbrush ready
anyway so our proof is inspired by again
the previous work sunflower results and
frictional conquer light work but the
implementation is different so I think
um
how much time do I have
I mean we have time until five but we
could stop anytime and we can do the
Restless Okay one can go on it's like
audience is interested so so yeah so
what I have in the next part is to prove
well maybe I can skip this or I can
leave this for the discussion session or
like after this talk and then move on to
open questions it's okay
[Laughter]
oh okay I don't know how the time time
language so I I was I was told that I'm
gonna have like 30 minutes of discussion
session after this talk is that true
yeah so maybe what you can do is yeah
you can do the open questions and still
you know if people want to leave they
have to leave they can leave and then I
guess who stays we can go okay he said
okay okay
for now let me skip the proof part and
then go on to open questions
so okay so this is where we are we know
that PC is at most is at least clearly
and at most PE times block L but still
so the calculator conjecture gives an
upper bound so still there is a gap
between the actual threshold and on
upper bound and so the natural question
is what characterize what characterizes
the gap between the expectation
threshold and the actual threshold so
proving the calculi conjecture is not
the end of the story but this is just
the beginning of the story
and in many cases this log l Gap is
tight and we have some examples but
there are some cases for which log l Gap
is not tight and we review them as good
test cases so we are still working on
like how working trying to trying to
understand the size of again what
characterizes the size of the gap
and so the first successful test case is
this something called the square of a
Hamilton cycle or because I don't have
so much time so let me not talk about
what it is but anyway this is a spanning
graph and the expectation threshold is n
to the negative one-half but the
conjectured upper bound or the
conjecture true threshold is also n to
the negative one-half so even if this is
a spanning graph but there is no Gap
and here you see this is the history of
improving the upper bound and I hope
people see how much effort we have to
put to improve just monologue and talk
on upper bound and finally we proved
that yeah we proved this you know
through Upper Bond
and for this one I think what's
interesting is we used uh the argument
in the fractional calculi so in all of
those work I mean on up to here all of
this work used something called
absorption method which is pretty uh
pretty involved but our argument is
pretty simple and our entire paper is
about like four to five page five to six
pages so the argument is pretty short
oh by the way our recent resolution of
the can color conjecture is also short
our entire paper is six pages and the
very last page is only for the
references it's our actual paper is not
very long
but again but that paper is short
because we didn't put any applications
of that
because all of the applications were
already in the previous papers
anyway so
and then there are some remaining good
test cases and the first example that I
put is to contain a triangle Vector
where our triangle Vector means a bunch
of disjoint triangles that looks like
this
so in this case we know that it was
proved by Johansson Khan and Wu that the
actual threshold is this times this
where this is the expectation threshold
and then we have this strange log and
fractional login Gap and we are trying
to understand this Gap and we are trying
to prove uh this bound using our
approach in the concali conjecture but
so far we don't know how to do this
and another example is another random
graph model that is called K out model
and roughly speaking in this model we
consider a different random model so
that there's no isolated vertices in the
first place so that means for each
vertex we just each vertex chooses some
number of like mates or some member of
neighbors so this way there there are no
isolated vertices and if we consider
this random graph model then we know
that for example if we consider a
perfect matching then we have this bond
which corresponds to P equals 1 over n
which means there's no I mean maybe I
should say
so in this this values corresponds to
there's no Gap
so it looks like if we if we post that
there's no isolated vertices then
there's no login Gap but so we are
trying to prove this result using our
approach in the conclight conjecture and
that's what that's one of the things
that we are doing now
okay so yeah and then thank you very
much for your attention and I'm going to
continue with the proof after this talk
foreign
making the color approximately it is not
related to fractional colors but more
like the idea of allowing some objects
not be covered somehow because you might
you know you're using the the sum of Q
to the size of s lower Bound in order to
establish that less than half in order
to establish the Q is a lower Bound for
the for PCF
um but even if you sort of Miss covering
some of some object there might still be
some sort of auxiliary argument that
tells you that you don't miss out right
so is there some idea like that so yeah
so our proof for the calculator uses
that argument which is that I use it the
idea of like so we called it a partial
cover so we don't cover the entire thing
when we see it
so that's going to show up in the food
store oh
since I have them I can ask a question
uh so you said earlier the Fourier
analysis does not uh didn't succeed in
probing uh what you proved as far as I
know yes so in the country I mean in in
the paper that can't Collide post to
their conjecture as well as far as I
know they also post some like possible
approaches using free analysis but yeah
I think I've heard that people tried but
they didn't right but does your approach
might say anything about the sharpness
of the thresholds the types of trash
definitely so or you just it's a matter
of just sharpening the technique or or
for sure the approach to propose does
not it's not going to have any bearing
on the sharpness of the threshold so as
yeah as far as I know our
technique doesn't have to do with
sharpness of the threshold
no questions
feel the informational question so this
is make some comments about
satisfiability
you talked about satisfiability in the
beginning of the talk but there people
talk about literals so you have both the
X and the complement
so how does that work with the notion of
monotonous
so okay I guess what what I know is so
in that sense if I do the conjecture
they actually care about the constant
factors
so you talked about uh not satisfiable
but somehow being a monotone probably
yeah
I thought it was like the values of the
variables are changed
stay
just continue
okay so we are here
um
let me have some more
okay so we want to prove this upper
bound on the concave conjecture and let
me just
reformulate so let me introduce our
reformulation
and what we actually what we actually
proved is this reformulation so in this
reformulation we think so we introduce
another hypergraph H and this H is just
a collection of all of the minimum
elements of f so for example if f is to
contain a perfect matching then H is the
collection of all of the perfect
matchings so this is just like like if f
is here then we consider we collect all
of the minimum elements oh sorry we all
of the minimum elements and this is H
then our reformulation is this
so we showed that there exists a
constant L which is different from K
such that for every L bounded H where
this L bounded means for f for every s
in h the size of s is at most l
so this just corresponds to the fact
that this the definition of l of f
right so this little L is just equal to
this little l
okay and we showed that if p is above
the expectation threshold of this
bracket H where because H is the
collection of all of the minimum
elements so this bracket H is just f
we just change our Viewpoint from an
increase in property to a hyper graph
so we said we showed that if p is larger
than the expectation threshold of f
which is this bracket H then with M this
quantity
and when you look at this so this is
just changing from a binomial random
variable to the random variable with
fixed size
so if we let M to be the expected size
of XP so this is basically the expected
size of XP
Times log of um l
right
so if we fix M to be the size to be the
expected size of XP Times log l then
this x m so this is a random subset of X
of size M so we just fix the fixed the
size and then we choose a set of the
given size and this x m contains a
member of H
this contains a member of h means XM
lens in X lens in F so x m is here this
is the meaning of XM contains some
member of H
and we showed that this probability
tends to 1 as L tends to the infinity
and I want to see if this reformulation
makes sense
so again we are talking about the upper
an upper bound on the threshold which
means if we are above this value then we
want to say that our random variable XP
lands in F with high probability
and then we just reformulated this
property by our XP contains a member of
H with high probability
oh so here but as long as as soon as we
I mean as long as we have this really
high probability statement that we can
handle this small Arrow Case by or just
to work Einstein no no but you have your
big address now for used basically
okay for the is
okay yeah
because they are not exactly Imports so
I just need to give my class they're
basically they understand
okay so okay okay what we did is
reformulate but can call it contractor
to this containment statement and this
is okay for my audience
is just we show this containment happens
with high probability
this is a variable so we showed that so
this all little of l means this is
little of one as L tends to the infinity
so L is a variable so for example we can
think about like L is the size of a
perfect matching or something
yeah the size XPS xn just means we
consider all of the subsets of X of size
m in the mutual's model yes
okay
I think now we are working with this
containment I containment or statement
that's what we do
so yeah okay so this is our statement
and I just visualized our situation so
this uh big rectangle this is our
universe X and then now we have H and
then those circles are the elements of H
okay so for example if we if our
increasing property is to contain a
perfect matching then those circles are
all of the perfect matchings in our in
our Edge set
and in this case we want to show that XM
so if we sprinkle our random elements
of size m
then at the end with high probability
our random set XM contains at least one
member of H with high probability
and if you have some maturity in this
area or knowledge in this area then I
think this start is Pretty Natural so we
choose our randoms at X which is another
name for XM just middle by little so we
do not choose our random set at once but
just little by little so in the first
stage we sprinkle some random elements
and in the second stage we sprinkle some
other random elements and we repeat this
and at the end of the day we want our
Windows offset X random subset W
contains a member s in H with high
probability
and so in this uh process we use
randomized algorithm which does we
iteratively produce a partial cover of
uh or partial cover whose name is U of w
so this depends on the choice of w and
because W is a random set so this is a
randomized algorithm because the entire
output depends on our choice of w
and here partial cover means as I said
we do not cover all of the elements in h
but we just cover some some parts of the
elements some of the elements of H that
is the notion of a partial copper
and here the main point of our
randomized algorithm is typically U of w
is p chip where P chip is the in the
second in the second item of the
definition of the expectation threshold
if you still remember that so P chip
means if we add up all of the s in this
cover and if we take P to the s
then this is small so in my definition
it was one half but actually can be
anything
and in our proof this small is actually
very small it's exponentially small
anyway so I really don't have time to
introduce what this randomized algorithm
is but if you want at the end maybe I
can give you a little bit hint of this
algorithm but
so
the really the main point is to show
that in this iterated algorithm so we
each each time we construct a partial
cover but typically this partial cover
is p chip there was the goal of our
algorithm and there was a clever point
that we that we I mean we borrowed this
agree the idea of this algorithm from
the sunflower work and the fraction but
our implementation was different yes
is the correct factor is related to the
empirical statistics of the sizes of the
extremo points
you're looking for some correct factor
that is within a range of log of the
largest size of a minimal element but
the picture you're painting suggests
that you should be looking at the
empirical statistics of the sizes of the
minimal elements
because some of them are big and some of
them are small so somehow
yeah but some of the true the true bound
may be related to the distribution of
the sizes of the minimal elements is
that true or not well so I don't know so
if we iterate this algorithm then
somehow it's very hard to analyze the
distribution of what's not of course
yeah I'm just asking about your your
guess that's all so basically just a big
picture
because we know that that upper bound is
always true in some cases for example if
we consider it perfect matching then
level is just the truth yeah but in a
perfect matching all the guys have got
the same time right I mean so but
tomorrow that is all the external
elements are going to have the same size
and the perfect matching but for more
General monotone property you might have
a wide variation with the sizes of the
what's the extreme elements and that
might determine what that Gap is so yeah
actually we use something like something
some idea like that to to prove the
square of the Hamilton cycle so there
there was no Gap and the way that we
achieved that is you basically be like
somehow used that of the thing with this
large like over it is very unlikely very
rare
property that you're looking at right
there are some minimal elements but they
might in general have a wide variation
in their sizes so I think the picture is
painting suggests that it's the
distribution of the sizes that might
control what the actual uh
professionals
so that means it's not just about a
craft property but we have this fire
distribution at the beginning we're not
just the largest size of the minimal
elements but how much what the impact of
statistics
another size is that's just a guess I'm
just wondering if you think
yeah I think yeah I think that makes
sense yeah okay
okay anyway so yeah
but somehow when I was working on this
problem always I we had some typical
examples and those were graph
containment so somehow we have this you
know uniform yeah yeah situation but I
think yeah but I understood yeah your
suggestion
okay anyway so we are in the middle of
this randomized algorithm and as I said
the main point of our algorithm is to
show that typically our partial copper
is p-chip which means this expectation
value is very small
and then
when our algorithm permeates then this
is a randomized algorithm so we do not
have any like any specific result but it
allows two possible outputs the first
output is either U covers H which means
so even if we have constructed a partial
cover but one possible output is this
partial cover is actually the entire
copper it covers all everything
and the second possible output is our
goal
so the second output is something
desirable but and the first output is
something not desirable and then what we
showed is but first the first output is
very unlikely which gives us the
conclusion that the second output is
much more likely it's very like it's uh
it happens with high probability
and then the way that we showed that one
is unlikely is just the definition of
the expectation threshold
so this is the situation so this
rectangle is the sample space which
refers to the choice of w choice of
algorithms at w
and our main point says that for most of
the choices of w u is cheap
the partial copper U is cheap and it's
very unlikely that you is expensive
and then now we apply our assumption so
we assumed that P is larger than the
expectation threshold what does this
mean this means the expectation
threshold is the largest value that
omits a chip cover that omits this
expectation small that admits a cover
whose expectation is small so that means
if p is above this expectation threshold
then we cannot have a chip cover
so that means if our U happens to cover
H then this event must be inside this
small area this is where one belongs to
because once again because if one
happens then you if U covers H then you
cannot be cheap by the definition of the
expectation threshold so one is here so
that means one is unlikely so that
concludes that we have two with high
probability so this ends the proof
so really the main the main part is how
to design this randomized algorithm and
then show that our Pressure cover is
usually cheap
and
so yeah but I don't know how much I can
explain about this randomized algorithm
and okay so let me like close for now
but if you're interested then I can say
a little bit more about how to design
our randomized algorithm
yep
let me stop here and then
okay
had the eggs finite but uh with this
theorem are you able like through some
limit argument for example to give a
solution or a better bound to a problem
whose statement does not live in the
finite world
ends okay yeah if n is infinite not
anything that if our God prompts that is
infinite
no no I mean like if if there is like if
say you wanted to throw something on the
square braid and you were approximating
the square grade except to buy larger
and larger
um you know finite number it's like is
there a statement which lives on the
infinite one that uh
you could use this for
eign
rather like a particular application I
don't think they're at this point
generalization like a theory you know
could you
and so she's asking generally says some
notion of pushes and stuff
so I don't know for sure
so what is the definition
we haven't defined it it needs to be
attention
what so what is the case one
color stage
so in our library
we always produce a
data set in the first possible output is
U is not just a partial cover but the
entire cover
White
oh no it just says that there are two
possible outputs and the desirable
output is number two so it's bad if one
happens you don't get two so in that
sense it's bad if you want to no it's
not like it won't happen then we don't
have to it's just saying that so in
order to say that you have this with
high probability we have to say that one
was not one is very unlikely
we can cover something did you cover
something but
in that case you're expensive
I think maybe the thing is like you
doesn't have to be
like you is not the same as ww is what
we want to
to uh contain a member of age yeah and
also this notion of cover this goes back
to Christian's question is cover
actually means you're inside some
hypervis right whereas you actually want
to contain some high products so
governing is kind of bad what are things
cheap ones are good
but those are just two possible outputs
so at this point there is no ethics but
what we want is number two and one way
to show that two happens with high
probability is to show them one is
unlikely okay so yes so you said it used
to randomized yes
oh okay yeah so it's not like it's a
deterministic algorithm surface of w
yeah so whenever we choose w we have you
so viewing is a product okay yes
I have another question so you said this
capital L is different from what you uh
ultimately have for the objective yeah
because we need some modification for
this analogy but use it because you
remove from extend to XP oh yeah then
also because you know here L goes to the
infinity so we need some constant
adjustment to handle small health
so in that statement L does not have to
be large the real statement of L is
large
statements
right yeah I'm sorry so but my question
is why is this capital L difference from
the capital K you get
because so here this statement is for
small and large
so this statement only covers large
small animals so if this small area is
largely enough
that is this capital L equal to Capital
okay
I think the answer is yes
but one of the reasons is
people can't
information for the standard speaker
yeah
foreign
but
I'm just curious it tells us complicated
what happens if you try to use the
second moment argument to group the
calculator yes
okay so
I haven't tried it but I know some
attempts to prove something using the
second method but it didn't work just
because the variables was too large
because it's very very responsible yes
so I'll ask a quick question to explain
why P comes in this argument right yeah
I mean so it's you explain why M has to
be proportional to Little P oh yeah
because we consider this exercise yeah
so what so where does log n come in this
argument oh so here the size of each wi
is exactly corresponds to p and then we
iterate to this by mobile times so
because you want to contain a set of
size l so yes yes yeah so it's like so
when we consider this product or
whatever any spanning graph we know that
if it's like so for example if
two content for for example let's
consider a path then we know that to
contain or path of size like a 0.95 then
we don't need to be small L Factor
Vector but because but if each time you
collect like 90 percent of our universe
so we know we know that we're going to
repeat this by a small bit of time so
that model exactly comes from them
foreign
possible outcomes
um
clever idea which is motivated by
sunflower okay
is
the final thoughts of questions
all right so thank you very much